pour soir maxime bernier bonsoir vous
n'estimez plus vos propos oui je suis
mes propos ce que j'ai dit c'est que
j'aurais pas dû finalement parlé de sa
situation physique malgré le fait que
elle et sa mère et les partisans de de
l'alarmisme climatique utilise
régulièrement je n'aurais pas dû faire
ça mais je me concentre sur ce qu'elle a
dit et je suis encore en désaccord avec
l'ensemble de ses propos bongo version
de partir au possible et bien pour le
bénéfice de 14 nous allons comparer les
twins 2 s'est tenue le 1er 2 et 3
septembre et ceux d'aujourd'hui en
dernière heure alors premier tweet que
je vous montre de septembre
quant à tony burke est clairement
mentalement instable l'autisme est aussi
obsessive compulsive trouve
l'alimentation des pressions léthargie
elles vivent dans une peur constante et
veut nous la communiquer je veux vous
paniquez la cité vous le citez que vous
sentiez la peur que j'ai chaque jour
aujourd'hui à 16h25 vous écrit j'ai
aussi plusieurs critiques à la suite
d'un tweet je mentionnais les problèmes
de santé mentale de créteil tandberg
qu'elle même et sa mère ont mis sur la
place publique mon but n'était
aucunement de dénigrer greta ou
quelconque souffre de telles conditions
mais le but et les étangs et que vous
avez émergé des critiques de toutes
parts absolue dit que vous l'avez je
l'avais attaqué où elle avait dénigré je
les assume et les propos que j'ai dit et
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit dans ce
deuxième tweet que je n'aurais pas dû
parler de sa situation physique malgré
le fait qu'on en parle parce que
lorsqu'elle parle de panique et qu'on
devrait tous paniqué comme vous l'avez
cité et qu'on devrait sentir la peur
comme à la salle chaque jour à cause
justement de cette urgence climatique
qui est selon moi complètement non
fondées et c'est mon point de vue
politique là dessus mais sur le sur le
dénigrement sur la question de la santé
mentale
lequel des deux maxime bernier faut-il
croire service
2 septembre ou celui d'aujourd'hui mais
je peux vous dire que c'est les deux
c'est le maxime bernier écrit quelque
chose et qu'ils se rétractent qui dit
que répondu maîtrise d'un manque de
jugement mais moi je dis que ce que
j'aurais pas dû les gens parlent
beaucoup de sa santé mentale pour
arriver et et faire en sorte que on
n'empêche des balades démocratique
ce quelqu'un qui attaquent madame greta
que 16 ans quand même qu'il attaque on
va tous eu tout de suite dire vous devez
pas attaquer une jeune fille comme ça
mais moi je la taxe sur ses propos -
est-ce que ça fait aujourd'hui qu'est
sur sa santé mentale dont j'ai c'est un
fait j'ai parlé du fait que c'est un
fait connu et j'aurais pas dû en parler
comme les autres en parle mais ce que je
dise qui est important c'est que les
gens de l'extrême gauche les radicaux
environnementalistes utilisation d un
bouclier pour faire anciens qu'on est
potes débat et il faut avoir des débats
anthony m on voyait venir mais votre
premier tweet était digne et sacré
certaines personnes l'ont vu comme ça
oui
et pour vous mais j'ai répondu j'ai
répondu aux critiques avec le fpi est ce
que ça a pris quand même trois jours
pour vous excuser qu'est ce que vous
faites pour vous garantir une place au
débat pourquoi vous êtes vous excuser
seulement après trois jours prénom en
réalisant il ya des gens qui m'ont dit
des personnes qui a des enfants qui sont
tissés qui est pensé être affectés par
cette déclaration là et j'ai précisé mon
propos il faut quand même rendre hommage
à cette jeune femme qui lutte contre ces
maladies là mais d'un autre côté aussi
les propos ont le droit de critiquer les
propos elle a décidé d'être un
personnage public
ses parents ont décidé de faire d'elle
personnages publics qui défend une cause
politique et on devrait être capable de
créer cette cause là aux autres doigts
vous parlez d'un débat rationnel autre
tweet de septembre
l'objectif est clair tolbert nous devons
changer parce que tout dans notre
société actuelle
ils veulent nous rendre plus pauvres
et/ou restreinte du logement au
transport en passant par l'alimentation
les voyages ce que nous consommons et
même se reproduire aujourd'hui vous dit
l'appel de greta a paniqué à transformer
radicalement la société sans autre débat
parce que nous n'avons plus de temps
avant d'éviter une catastrophe est
particulièrement dangereux surtout pour
les gens d'ici et d'ailleurs quelle
influence cybercité vous faire c'est
d'essayer la tuer ce que j
effectivement écouter ont fait part aux
jeunes aujourd'hui on leur dit si on
fait rien si la société fait rien contre
l'urgence climatique
il ya un risque ça soit la fin du monde
et ça je dis que c'est pas responsable
de faire ça et c'est important d'avoir
ce débat là je suis seul qui le fait
mais si on revient assez souvent vous
êtes le seul qui le fait c'est à dire
que vous êtes seul contre l'onu les
scientifiques du giec transcender
particulier quand avoir effectivement et
c'est pour ces amateurs et c'est pour ça
justement qu'on en parle aujourd'hui je
suis heureux qu'on en parle cette
hystérie climatique urgence climatique
n'existe pas on faisait ça il ya dix ans
il ya dix ans vous en rappeler c'était
al gore qui nous parlaient qu'on se sont
fait rien le niveau des océans vont
monter ça va être la fin pour certaines
villes qui sont près des océans ont à
chaque dix ans on nous parle d'urgence
climatique et on peut pas baser les
politiques publiques sur la terre mes
relations
on parle de peur actuellement pour
fermer le débat peur et urgence pour
faire en sorte qu'on ne débatte plus et
que c'est réglé
moi je suis en train de dire qu'on veut
bâtir les politiques publiques sur la
raison et sur la raison et les faits et
si je proposais la science et oui
effectivement y croyez à la science va
effectivement monsieur roy pas les
scientifiques du giec pourquoi pas l'onu
j'en ai vu plusieurs scientifiques que
plusieurs scientifiques sont d'accord à
dire que les changements climatiques
existent et j'ai toujours dit que le
changement climatique existe les
changements climatiques la normalité
dans le climat c'est le changement et
mais ce que je suis contre les autres
propos n'en de la théorie de l'urgence
thématique c'est de dire que ce n'est
pas la faute principale de l'activité
humaine c'est ça la différence et il ya
des scientifiques comme patrick moore
qui a quitté justement l'organisation
qui la font dit lui-même mines pis il
est un scientifique
il dit que plusieurs autres facteurs et
c'est ça que je veux débattre il ya
l'activité humaine qui peut être un
facteur mais pas le facteur principal
des changements climatiques actuels et
surtout pas d'urgence climatique a
changé leur niveau de vie à faire en
sorte qu'on voyage - est-ce qu'on change
l'ibu est ce que vous voudrez l'absolu
brassens ou masquer les laisse pas jouer
vous même sur la peur en disant que
c'est quelqu'un qui sert depuis bouclier
même que je vienne mans
dijon doit pas nick et elle nous dit que
l'on doit paniqué et on doit aussi être
sensible à sa peur et avoir peur comme
elle et il faut changer notre mode de
vie pour faire en sorte de répondre à
une crise climatique une urgence
climatique qui selon moi donc si tu
parles alors le tweet du 1er septembre
les alarmistes et climatique oui allait
se servent des enfants pour faire leur
propagande tout comme certains
terroristes s'en servent comme bouclier
pour se cacher derrière us se protéger
des attaques ce sont des lâches sans
aucune morale voilà ce que tu es bottes
vous un message à djerba conseiller je
m'agite de monsieur trudeau et
aujourd'hui vous êtes au contraire c'est
une femme courageuse qui assume
surmonter ses problèmes et on utilise
permet aux jouets livres mais
l'utilisent pourquoi dites-vous boudier
un jeune fille de 16 ans d'avoir des
convictions
si vous aviez une fille de 16 ans ne
respecte jamais mais elle décidé d'être
sur la place publique avec ses parents
librement aux librement et ont le droit
de critiquer ses propos et c'est ce que
je tenterai de faire c'est ce que je dis
l'erreur que j'ai fait c'est de parler
de sa situation physique de sa situation
personnelle de sa situation que tout le
monde parle mais lorsqu'on veut parler
de guetta g j'aurais pas dû parler de
ces situations là et c'est ce que j'ai
dit aujourd'hui croire à la science même
temps vous citez ainsi une personne
patrick mois mais est ce que les autres
scientifiques du giec qui signe depuis
1990 des rapports oui où on parle
d'urgence climatique le secrétaire
général des nations unies monsieur
goûter res par me regarder dans les
regards des fumistes ces gens là
regardez dans les faits où elles ont des
faits mais c'est là que je n'existais jo
je le crois pas
mais pourquoi devrait-on vous croire
mais parce que c'était moi je demande
aux gens je ne mens pas aux gens de me
croire sur parole je demande aux gens de
faire une recherche de regarder des deux
je fais la longueur je fais appel à
l'intelligence des gens j'ai jeté et
jamais dans l'autre point de vue au
débat est ce qu'on doit et cesser dans
une démocratie on veut empêcher le débat
il ya plusieurs orientations et
plusieurs oui merci je mets un heureux
d'être ici il ya plus entre 2,02
scientifiques qui croient pas l'urgence
climatique y crois pas que l'homme est
la cause principale des changements
climatiques
max evans est une cause très importante
mais pas la constitution et la situation
s'aggrave et donc il faut agir tout
l'est par exemple sa grève donnez moi
les expos wells aggrave la situation
actuelle et ligier abbas et moi pose les
questions que je suivais classé dans le
dernier aussi sur les aux siens j'en
suis à sion est ce que les niveaux de
ces augmentations à ce que c'est c'est
non alors messieurs si vous avez des
ambitions faire élire député alors tout
était prévisible dans la prochaine
campagne qui va devrait commencer un
prochain jour si vous déteniez si vous
étiez élue miss earth pour facile dans
votre compte et de là si vous dites les
gens deviennent faciles à la malbouffe
et éteignez la salle j'aime j'aime les
défis
est-ce que vous déteniez si vous
déteniez la balance du pouvoir avec une
voix un député tout ça iriez-vous vers
vos anciens absolument relève des
consommateurs je ne ferai pas je
respecterai les principes du parti nous
sommes d'apolitisme faisons la politique
différemment basé sur quatre principes
l'équité et le respect l'art est un
outil la liberté et ces quatre principes
là sont à la base on parle de nos trois
petits on fait de la politique
différemment on card est très chose des
vrais sujets qui intéressent et cas
natives comme l'immigration comme les
changements climatiques on en parle
comme l'économie et c'est important
c'est important d'être au débat national
avec les autres chiffres pour justement
avoir un vrai débat d'idées est ce que
vous êtes fier je pense d'être populiste
certaine manière plus intelligente jouer
est ce que nous réformes sont basées sur
des études sérieuses mais d'un document
et bien on les renvoie vassal et vois
pas ce qu'on peut lire sur le site
internet allait droit au point qu'on
peut penser qu'en liant les
scientifiques du giec de l'onu des
partis politiques des différents
gouvernements même les pétrolières
hôtelière autres scientifiques y ont
participé aux travaux de l'onu et qui
ont dit qu'ils ont quitté les ducs ont
quitté l'onu justement parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas d'accord on peut
l'utiliser on politise un débat est
actuellement
moi je dis regardons les faits regardons
un autre côté de la médaille et c'est ce
que je fais est ce que vous visez donc
en étant profil et vous même
sur la peur je vis sur l'intelligence
des gens j'ai pas peur de faire les
débats et je demande aux gens de
regarder qu'est ce qu'on a à offrir et
ce sera aux juges et dites moi si vous
êtes vraiment repentant là est ce que
vous allez les est facile tous les
premiers du 3 2 qui reste je les reçois
d'histoire je ne réécris pas l'histoire
sénat et celle à ce processus qu'on est
celle des frères mais en région pajr
quelqu'un qui m'aurait quelqu'un il va
tout et votre tweet ou vous la dénigrer
c'est ce que j'ai fait j'assume ce que
j'ai fait et je ne fasse pas d'histoire
et puis voilà merci monsieur vernis
merci